Dr. what's the best thing to announce
whilst you're breaking the fast the dua
or the prayer or any announcement which
is uh specific for breaking the fast
many Muslims they say many duas before
they put the food in their mouth and all
these dua that is there of breaking the
fast most of them they are z or they
unauthentic their mud the authentic dua
while breaking the fast is of sunbud
volume number to book of fasting hadith
number 2350 in which the prophet recited
it's
mentioned inshallah which means that the
thirst has been quenched the veins has
been
moistened and the reward is
certain if Allah is now though this dua
is authentic some of them say this dua
before they put their food in their
mouth
before they break the fast which by
meaning itself it doesn't make sense.
This dua is supposed to be said after
you put the food in the mouth. The right
thing is before you put the food in the
mouth you have to say bismillah. That
was a practice of our beloved prophet
wasallam. And after he ate the dates and
water or he ate food and he had water
then this dua makes
sense inshallah which means my thirst
has been quenched. Only when you have
water can your thirst be quenched. So
how can you say this dua before you
break the fast? Only after you break the
fast and you had dates and you had the
fruits or you had the food and then you
had water can you say that my thirst had
been quenched and my veins have
moistened and the reward is certain
inshallah and there are various other
hadith of our beloved prophet wasallam.
So as far as the dua immediately before
breaking the fast sayah and after
breaking when your thirst is quenched
you have to read this dua. But there are
other hadith it's mentioned in Maja
volume number three hadith number 1752
that the beloved prophet said that the
dua of three people are never unanswered
mean they're always answered that is the
dua the supplication of a just ruler and
imam the dua of a person who fast until
he breaks his fast and the dua of an
oppressed. The same message is repeated
in Maja volume number three had number
1753 that a person who fasts his dua
accepted when he breaks his fast. So
before breaking the fast you can do any
dua you can pray to Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala your own language in the
Arabic any dua you can ask from Allah
ask for forgiveness ask for supplication
whatever you feel you can ask this is
the best time before breaking the